um but welcome man
you're having a a pretty crazy year um
your project idols would you say that as
a body of work this has been the
your biggest body of work as far as like
recognition
performance because you had it like like
where are you ranking this one at
i would say this is my most free body of
work and this is my most
like honest body of work this is the one
like the ones that i'm most proud of
you know like you know every other body
of work has done different things for me
but this one is just like yo all right
this dude can really
do his damn thing you know yeah for
people who are listening who might not
have heard of you uh you put a record
out called idols
and um the the concept of the album
was really to pay homage to
your idols in the music industry it's an
ep each record is dedicated to
uh we got what kendrick cole drake kanye
50 50. yeah and then one to yourself one
to myself
yeah yeah um when you were making like
like was was the idea a conscious idea
when you were recording it or
did you like hear the songs be like you
know what
this this was like like like or did you
do it was everything on purpose
um i think half of the project was on
purpose i think i did i did one song
and i was actually trying to mimic code
like i want to do a cold flow on this
one and that was a
record that i didn't even make the
project actually because i had two code
records
so i'm like yo this this is dope and
then i did a kendrick record i'm like oh
this is dope you know
and then after that i was just like yo
i'm gonna put this all together and make
this a body of work you know and like
the last
ones i did was the fallback record for
myself and then
the higher hopes that kanye went because
that was like the toughest thing to do
because kanye is like
a swiss army knife so how do you oh yeah
yeah yeah kanye's
he's my favorite artist yeah he's an
artist for real bro yeah
i'm more than a fan of jesus is king i'm
not gonna lie but you know
discography wise nobody could [ __ ] with
you yeah i think i think the thing that
i got from jesus is king is
i felt that peace listening to it it
wasn't the best lyrical album it wasn't
the best mix album at all
but it felt peaceful it was great
production there was some great
production on there shout out to bugs
the beast